possession of property is not like in
this scenario not intense of the law
does not mean that it's yours okay and
then when they find out they got your
stolen property it's like oh it's just a
storage issue i'm just storing it for
him i would i didn't actually steal it i
was storing it i was storing it but that
would be the same thing it's like oh
well you know like for the kid who stole
my pokemon card it's like oh well
wait it was in a case i just have an
empty case right now where did the
charizard card go right like it is that
scenario of like i have the thing what
was that what's a charizard card what is
this charizard yeah i don't know what
this charizard pokemon it is the
holographic oh pokemon it starts with
charmander oh i know i know come on
pokemon yeah i don't know about pokemon
dude pokemon he's going to be
all up in our private text later but
boomer don't know pokemon and you
[ __ ] i know i don't know but this is
the same thing whatever it could be a
collectible baseball card michael jordan
card
michael jordan okay chicago bulls boom
there was a card which i did have wasn't
stolen but you put them in the case you
have michael jordan no no no
i've got a lot of i've got a lot of good
micro courts they used to be worth a lot
way back when oh yeah yeah yeah well
cards have kind of come back in there
they've actually
have they i don't know i am trading
cards have come back now but anyway this
would be the same thing if the kid took
a michael jordan card and i had it in a
little case that said like oh here's the
you know mint or here's what it was it's
a little case
and then i find the case and he's like
well i just took the case
no i did not get the card back i didn't
know cynthia no because when i found out
when i found out the kid who took who
stole my pokemon card he'd already sold
it
[ __ ] yeah but this is the same
thing same goddamn thing do you think
that guy you stole your card votes for
trump
100
100 percent
that's a [ __ ] trumpeter right there
that's percentage